I thought it was very important to come
up and and see for myself the the
seriousness of the situation here in
welly abridging it is that there is a
still a substantial risk and that's why
I really wanted to congratulate the
emergency services because this is a
major problem if that dam goes you know
the potential destruction that that can
wreak on the the whole of the village
below on livelihoods on on families on
homes and that's why it's so important
everybody listens to the authorities and
make sure they don't go back to their
homes until they get we go ahead well
it's looking dodgy but stable is how I
would describe it I mean they've done an
amazing job as you can tell they're the
Chinook's have brought in about 400 bags
of stone huge huge quantities of
aggregate gone in to that hole and you
still can't really tell that the hole
has been filled so there's a major major
structural problem with the dam what
needs to happen now is that the water
all needs to come out there needs to be
a proper repair rebuild of that dam
that's obviously what we're going to do
down the build with those great ways to
allow water to stand out are we
concerned that this happens with some
rain clearly I was interesting I was
talking to her one of the villagers from
from Whaley bridge who said that he
remembered something like this happening
50 years ago we've had an exceptional
weather event we must make sure that
this dam can cope with it in the future
that will mean a major rebuild clearly
well as you know we're putting a huge
amount into flood defences of all kind
of about 3 billion 2.6 billion and were
put into a thousand separate flood
defences I think that this is a
particularly localized issue
tonight this is something that is
affecting this community and it's just
been amazing to be here listening to
families who really taken it in their
stride pulled together and I do
congratulate the emergency services on
what they've done it's been truly
phenomenal and just finally you can
record election now you only have a one
seat majority I think the British people
look they had an election in 2015 they
had a referendum in 2016 there and now
they're actually in 2017 and what they
really want is for the politicians to
get on and honor the mandate of the
people and that's what I'm going to do